so in der heutigen sitzung behandeln wir
zwei ganz interessante philosophen
nämlich zuerst noch mal den isaac newton
frage ist diese bauten philosoph würde
sagen schon obwohl er natürlich genauso
gut ein mathematiker oder natürlich noch
mehr ein physiker genannt werden könnte
aber wir finden bei ihm sehr sehr
wichtige überlegungen zum wesen der zeit
und des raumes auch der geschwindigkeit
die so abstrakt sind dass er ein
philosoph genannt zu werden verdient
nicht finden bevor wir jetzt aber heute
auf minuten noch einmal zu sprechen
kommen und dann auf leibnitz und seine
auseinandersetzung mit 10 0 clark der
ein schüler von minuten waren möchte ich
noch mal ganz zu beginn bisschen die
rede über die zeit problematisieren also
wir müssen uns überlegen wie wir
überhaupt über zeit reden ist eine
substanz ist ins objekt ich habe das so
beschrieben mit der zusammenfassungen
wir sagen die zeit fließt die zeit
verrinnt entsprechen wir so zeit als
eine substanz die mir sagen die zeit
läuft verläuft und dass sie flüchtete
sogar dann fassen wir sie als ein
subjekt auf was ich was etwas tun kann
das ist natürlich eine
hochproblematischen metaphorische rede
und wir müssen aufpassen also natürlich
können wir so drüber reden aber wir
sollten jetzt nicht die probleme dadurch
erzeugen dass wir das problem falsch
darstellen oder
das problem metaphorisch so auskleiden
dass uns durch die ausleitung die
größten probleme ist noch bevorstehen
und das eigentliche problem gar nicht
richtig ins sichtfeld gerät also können
wir überhaupt die zeit nicht
metaphorisch beschreiben
schwierige frage natürlich können wir
darüber metaphorisch reden die metapher
hat er immer so ein terzi um kooperation
ist wie sie alle wissen es gibt zwar
eine überschneidung zwischen dem bild
ausdruck und der sache wie sie ist also
eine analogie oder wie auch immer
also insofern können wir natürlich
zufrieden aber es sollten immer
aufpassen wenn wir das tun und dann das
ist die frage die mich ganz besonders
interessiert ist die zeit überhaupt ein
gegenstand oder ihr sie nicht nur eine
bedingung oder so eine möglichkeit
ich habe jetzt in der zusammenfassung
davon gesprochen dass es dass sie auch
ein rahmen sein könnte natürlich wenn
ich jetzt sagt einrahmen bin ich wieder
metaphorisch jetzt klar
also das ist auch so die frage die sich
jetzt zwischen leibnitz und newton
gestellt hat also newton vertritt die
auffassung dass es so was wie eine
absolute zeiten absoluten raum gibt also
einen raum und zeit immer sehr analog
sehr ähnlich gestimmt und ich habe das
in der zusammenfassung so beschrieben
dass ich gemeint hatte man könnte das
wie so ein großes gefäß verstehen
vielleicht ein großes gefäß ist der
absolute raums ein großes gefängnis
und der bleibt ganz konstant und
alles was darin ist das ist ein
zeitliches abati das ist dann die
falsche zeit wie wie auch newton sagt
oder die die scheinbare zeit so war es
an so bewegungen festgemacht wird wie
tagesabläufe wie revolutionen der erde
um die sonne und erhebt davon eben diese
absolute waren mathematische zeit ab ja
also das ist die frage wie wir sollten
wir darüber reden und diese dritte frage
hier ist zeit ein gegenstand oder nur
eine bedingung oder möglichkeit ein
gefüge eine ordnung oder eine relation
diese frage die ist ganz zentral im
zentrum der debatte die wir heute
behandeln werden jetzt möchte ich aber
noch mal kurz zurückgehen auf diesen
netten herrn newton und sein begriff der
absoluten zeit
man hat ja dieses werk verfasst
mathematischen prinzipien der natur
lehre und das große verdienst besteht
darin natur die physis das physikalische
mathematisierung erschlossen zu haben
also gewisse formale verhältnisse in der
natur entwicklung zu erkennen und diesen
diese formalen verhältnisse dann nach
mathematischen prinzipien zu analysieren
ich habe da das beispiel gebracht das
verhältnis von geschwindigkeit und
beschleunigung oder es gibt verhältnis
von geschwindigkeiten beschleunigung ist
dies ein ab leitungs verhältnis wie sie
ja alle wissen also die ableitung oder
differenzial rechnung wird ja gleich
newton wie leibniz zugesprochen also es
kennt das alles die erste ableitung
einer funktion die zweite usw
und jetzt hat newton gezeigt dass man
solche rein mathematischen ab leitungs
verhältnis auch auf physikalische größen
anwenden kann dass ich also
geschwindigkeit und beschleunigung oder
auch energie wenn ich integrale wenn ich
als ein integral habe dass ich das das
verschiedene größen sich in der physik
sondern danach ab leitungs verhältnissen
verhalten also apathisch mathematische
erkenntnisse angewendet auf die natur
und erkannt dass sie sich darin finden
lassen also die natur mit der können wir
rechnen auf die können wir zählen
sozusagen jedenfalls zu guten zeiten
noch heutzutage sieht das wie sie alle
wissen anders aus wenn wir in sehr sehr
kleine bereich uns begeben oder in sehr
großen dimensionen aufhalten wenn wir
die lichtgeschwindigkeit betrachten die
sitze fast 300.000 kilometer pro sekunde
dann greifen diese prinzipien von newton
einfach nicht mehr also diese prinzipien
die juden hier entdeckt hat die gelten
eben für unsere lebenswelt für
bewegungsabläufe die eben hier in
sichtweite sag ich mal sind da geld gilt
das alles und mit gegenständen die wir
im alltag begreifen können und die wir
sehen können selbst die wir mit
mikroskopen seinerzeit sehen konnten da
gilt diese sogenannte klassische physik
perfekt da können wir alles wunderbar
ausreden wenn wir aber in diese
grenzbereiche kommen also in nähe von
lichtgeschwindigkeit selbst mit halber
lichtgeschwindigkeit und in sehr kleine
bereiche vorstoßen also quanten und
sowas dann galt die so einfach nicht
mehr
und dann müssen wir anders über diese
dinge reden und können das nicht mehr so
machen wie es newton getan hat und
darauf werden wir auch in der nächsten
übernächsten sitzung zu sprechen kommt
wenn es dann um alles
einsteins spezielle relativitätstheorie
geht und jetzt habe ich ein paar fragen
wieder hier die sind auch schon von der
letzten sitzung übernommen also was
versteht minuten unter der absoluten
zeit wie verhält sich news
zeitverständnis zudem zeitverständnis
bei aristoteles und augustinus genau das
sind so diese zwei fragen und ich möchte
hier auch noch mal ganz kurz auf die a3
und die bereiche zu sprechen kommen das
hatte ich ja in der zusammenfassung an
nochmal ausführlich beschrieben weil das
gibt die bereit und die der namensgeber
ist dieser mctaggart
ein philosoph des frühen zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts und auf den werden wir auch
noch am ende dieses seminar ist also
nicht dieser heutigen sitzung sind des
gesamten seminars zu sprechen komme ich
möchte aber vorweg greifen dient mal
einführen weil sie sehr hilfreich ist
diese unterscheidung von ihnen noch mal
jemand was mit der arbeit der zeit
gemeint ist was hat es damit auf sich
genauso könnte man sagen die subjektive
zeit manche sagen auch manche
philosophen sagen auch die dass seine
präsent ist ische zeit auffassung also
wonach eben besonders die gegenwart
wichtig sei also präsent ist tisch oder
subjektive zeit subjektiv natürlich
jetzt nicht so als ob für den 1 die zeit
schneller verläuft für die anderen
verläuft sie langsamer dass es damit
nicht gemeint sie läuft genauso schnell
helfer jede und jeden in dieser reihe
aber das wichtige ist einfach das zeit
beschreibungen dort in mexikanischer
natur sind oder auch relativer natur
sind damit ist gemeint wenn ich sage
jetzt oder sagen morgen dann hängt das
immer von meiner jeweiligen gegenwart ab
also von dem zeitpunkt in dem ich oder
zu dem ich diese aussage tätigen wenn
ich also morgen gestern sage wurde heute
gestern sind damit ist extension also
also letztendlich dass der gegenstand
der bereich der damit betroffen ist ein
verschiedener also der wahrheit' wert
eine aussage die in mexikanische fast
ist hängt ab von dem zeitpunkt zu dem
sie getätigt wurden
das ist ja ganz klar ob ich jetzt heute
sage morgen wird das passieren
oder wenn ich in zehn jahren sage morgen
wird das passieren ist einfach morgen
betrifft einen anderen einen anderen
zeitpunkt und diese relativität von
hinweisenden wörtern also morgen gestern
in der vergangenheit vor fünf jahren
solche solche aussagen und der
relativität hängt damit dass nach der
aare eben die gegenwart sich immer
gewandelt
und das ist dann diese vorstellung
dieses fließen derzeit durch ein subjekt
hindurch und die frage fließende mit der
zeit oder fließt die zeit durch uns dann
durch diese fragen die eben solche in
mexikanischen ausdrücke betreffen die
hängen mit derart zusammen und die b das
ist jedoch mal im gegensatz dazu noch
genau also vielleicht könnte man hier
sagen objektive zeit in
anführungsstrichen zeit und das ist die
subjektive zeit aber wirklich subjektiv
nicht im sinne der relativität das eben
für die einen dem einen die zeit
schneller verläuft haben das hätte hält
das objekt ganz subjektive zeit objekt
genau subjekt bezogen finde ich auch
besser geht als es in mexikanische es
gibt ein zentrum und das ist
gewöhnlichen subjekt für das eben die
zeit in vergangenheit gegenwart und
zukunft jeweils auftritt
ok und die mathematik und physik vor
allem die betrachtet die zeit eben unter
einem sagen ob man eterna liz tischen
gesichtspunkt idealistisch heißt unter
dem gesichtspunkt der ewigkeit da habe
ich also jetzt nicht ein subjekt zu
einem zeitpunkt was das zentrum derzeit
betrachtung ist und da habe ich die
ganze zeit drei vor mir liegen sozusagen
ausgebreitet liegen
natürlich gibt es da auch ein früher
später aber dieses früher oder später
ist nicht abhängig von einem ehemaligen
subjekte sich zu einem zeitpunkt
befindet ich kann auch der bär immer
sagen ereignis aber früher als eigenes b
und das kann ich objektiv behaupten zu
jedem zeitpunkt das hängt nicht von dem
subjekt ab natürlich geht da viel
verloren weil sowas wie ein zukunfts
bewusstsein wie ein vergangenheit
bewusst sein vor allem aber auch so was
wie eine gegenwart eine erlebte
gegenwart und ihre phänomenale bedeutung
die hat nach db keine berechtigung
keinen sinn interessiert mich das geht
also zeit verhältnisse ganz abstrakt
ganz allgemein mit der b3 kann nicht
rechnen auf die kann ich zählen
ich kann zeit differenzen mir anschauen
ich kann zeit punkte als werte in
formeln einsetzen ich kann als
ausrechnen
brauche ich nicht zu wissen ob es jetzt
für jemanden gegenwert die zukünftige
vergangen ist das spielt für das
ergebnis einer formel einer
physikalischen rechnung keine rolle es
geht also um zeit beträge sogar es geht
gar nichts das ist er auch darum was
jetzt in der zeit früher war
wenn man nicht jetzt von erdgeschichte
wert für sich sprechen wenn wir aber
wenn wir wenn wir die wirte die
theoretische physik betrachten so
scheint mir jetzt geht es der physik gar
nichts zählt darum zu fragen was war
jedes früher als das andere absolut
betrachtet also wann war dieses ereignis
aber man war dieses also hat die feste
position im zeit stark interessierte für
sie nicht höchstens wenn es jetzt um
kosmologie geht und man fragt ja wie
viele sekunden nach dem urknall
die tausendstel millionsten sekunden
nach dem urknall war das dann wird
dieser zeitpunkt vielleicht wichtig aber
in der in der meisten zeit geht es um
zeit beträge wie viel energie ist ist
ausgestrahlt worden im zeitrahmen von
fünf sekunden ja oder drei sekunden
später
wo befindet sich dieses teilchen drei
sekunden später
und da ist nicht von interesse wann
jetzt dieses zeit teilchen bei drei
sekunden später war im jahr 2010 im jahr
2050 das interessiert die für sich es
geht um zeit beträge eigentlich gar
nicht so sehr um zeitpunkt würde ich
sagen also kann man das noch ein
bisschen weiter problematisieren ich
glaube dass der physik dadurch etwas
entgeht also ich bin das jetzt sehr
kritisch wenn man sagt zeit sollte man
nur nach dem nach der b3 betrachten weil
wir hier von derzeit abstrahierend wir
schon jetzt kann man es gibt zwei
auffassungen kann sagen nein die
wirkliche zeit es ist während die
arbeiter kommt halt noch sowas
subjektive sind zu da kommt halt nur
subjekt mit hinein
so kann man es auch sehen dann wäre das
einfach nur überflüssig oder redundant
seine arbeitszeit beschreibung
das würden sicherlich für die
naturwissenschaftler sagen auch mit
guten gründen
aber ich glaube dass das eine
reduktionistischen auffassung von zeit
ist und dass wir wenn wir dieses
phänomen der zeiten seiner ganzen tiefe
verstehen wollen eben besonders auch auf
die a3 schauen müssen
das ist so meine these aber sie können
sich selbst ihre eigene meinung dazu
bilden im rahmen im laufe dieses
semester wenn wir verschiedene theorien
dazu betrachtet haben
natürlich geht zeit nicht nur im
zeitempfinden auf dass es klar und wir
müssen auch wirklich ganz knallharte
unter logische fragen uns stellen
ebensolche ob es jetzt eine absolute
zeit gibt ob es nur eine relative zeit
gibt was das überhaupt ist das ist klar
und da ist auch nicht mehr ganz so
sicher
oder ganz so klar auf welche diese
reihen sich solche fragen jetzt beziehen
ja also die frage nach dem absoluten
raum ist es absolut zeit ist das jetzt
eine frage die die haie oder die bären
also muss man sich immer auch belegen
oder auf beides mit eckart kennt ja noch
drei
die möchte jetzt aber gar nicht
einführen sie kommen noch als jedenfalls
kann uns die rede die unterscheidung von
a3 und so eine art koordinatensystem an
die hand geben mit dem wir die
jeweiligen theorie betrachten können
augustinus den ersten denke den wir
gesprochen haben
der ist natürlich ein ganz klarer
analyst der ara bitte
musik zb
also über historische meinen sie
historische ja gute gute fragen also die
vergangenheit denn wenn sie es so
sprechen dass es in der vergangenheit
war dann sagen sie das natürlich von
einem subjektiven standpunkt aus
es könnte ja irgendwann mal auch das was
morgen oder in zehn jahren ist vergangen
sein
es ist jetzt noch nicht dann hängt es
natürlich stark von dem subjekt ab aber
wir können natürlich versuchen so eine
kulturgeschichte auch nach der baby zu
beschreiben dass wir so ein zeitstrahl
ansetzen und dann einfach ganz objektiv
die gesamte kulturgeschichte menschheit
an unsere super passieren lassen hat
dann müssen wir uns zum göttlichen
betrachtung punkt hin bewegen was wir
praktisch nicht können weil wir die
ganze zeit nicht überschauen können
aber das müssen wir dann praktisch
machen über uns über die zeit erheben
also die zeit überblicken die gesamte
zeit über blicken also aus der zeit drei
herauszutreten ich mir selbst ein
derzeit zu unterliegen sondern die zeit
muss uns unterliegen nach so einem
auffassung und dann können wir also ein
riesen zeitstrahl teilnehmen und sagen
hier war das hier war das hier war das
und im jahr 2030 wurde das erfunden und
so weiter und so fort darunter liegen
wenn ich derzeit darüber blicken wir sie
dass ihr sohn sondern perspektive eines
göttlichen wesens müsste man sich das so
vorstellen so vielleicht aber wenn wir
neben die rede von vergangenheit und
sowas ins spiel kommt dann können ist
das klare signale dafür dass wir uns in
der aare
also dann gehen wir jetzt mal hier auf
die frage noch mal bei youtube bisschen
ein also ich habe dir auch schon
vorgelesen zumal er sagt zeitraum
abwägung als allen bekannt erkläre ich
nicht bemerken nur dass man gewöhnlich
diese größen nicht anders als in bezug
auf die szene auf fast und so gewisse
vorurteile entstehen deren aufhebung man
sie passend in absolute und relative
ware und scheinbare mathematische
ungewöhnlich unterscheidet als er sagt
es gibt eben eine zeit das ist die
absolute zeit die können wir auch noch
als die wahre zeit nur die mathematische
zeit ansehen und es gibt eben die
gewöhnliche zeit die relative und die
scheinbare zeit die absolute waren
mathematische zeit dass also die gute
zeit sozusagen die verfliest ansicht und
vermöge ihre natur gleichförmig und ohne
beziehung aufregend keinen äußeren
gegenstand sie wird auch so mit dem
namen dauer belegt also minuten hatte
jetzt hier natürlich eine metapher
wiederverwendet fließt fließt an sich es
ist ganz schwierig für seine schnell wie
kann eine absolute zeit an sich fließen
also man muss die wie kann man sich
jetzt dieser zeit vorstellen ist ganz
schwierig vielleicht auch eine abhebung
von einer anderen zeit vorstellung wie
kann ich denn die absolute zeit mir
jetzt denken also die zeit an sich
derzeit fluss als solche nicht
irgendwelche gegenstände die sich in der
zeit verändern also jetzt liege ich da
einen apfel auf einen tisch und mit der
zeit wird er faul und wird schlecht und
irgendwann ist nicht mehr da das ist
nicht die zeit sondern es muss dir eine
reine verfließen selbst sein
da steht so kann sich schwierig
genau wie kann denn wie kann man sich
denn das verfließen als solches da
vorstellen
man kann das verfließen doch immer nur
vor dem hintergrund etwas bemessen was
nicht verfolgt ist schwierig ne absolute
verpflichten werden dass bei aristoteles
gesehen wo es um die frage ging ist die
zeit kann die zeit schneller oder
langsamer vergeben hat in meinem handy
kann zeit muss man der aristoteles die
zeit muss konstant zeigen derzeit können
ja dieser konstant ablaufende zeit
können wir erst ermessen ob sich etwas
schneller und langsam weg die zeit muss
sind fixer hintergrund sagen diese aber
weiter die relative scheinbar
ungewöhnliche zeit ist ein viel bares
und äußerliches entweder genaues oder
ungleiches maß der dauer des man sich
gewöhnlich statt der waren zeit bedient
die stunde tag monat ja bisher ist das
jetzt ein unklar
um unter umständen ungleiches maß warum
denn warum sollten wir auf so was nicht
uns konzentrieren wenn wir wirklich über
was aber wenn ich es auf die
konzentration
ja muss nicht als wäre möglich muss aber
nicht um den zeit er meint hier schon
die objektiv ist also die stunde wie sie
eben vergeht und der tag der vergeht und
das ja wir vergeben
warum warum nicht solche sachen
richtig das hat man aber auch erst
nachweisen könnte dass also die
erddrehung also die drehung der erde um
die sonne
dass die nicht exakt ein jahr ist was
auch immer jetzt ein jahr ist wenn man
jetzt sagt anja ist eben die umdrehung
geehrte um die sonne
organisierte um drehung der erde um die
sonne an ja aber die umdrehung der erde
um die sonne ist eben nicht immer
dieselbe strecke also die erde hat man
erst ganz in kürze in jüngster zeit um
1900 anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
hat man festgestellt dass die amplitude
dass der erdung drehung der radius dass
der fünf meter variieren kann also mal
meist erde fünf meter weiter weg von der
sonne und diese wenigen 5 metern sehr
praktisch so gut wie nichts 5 meter im
verhältnis der zonen relation ist ja
eigentlich nichts diese fünf meter
auslenkung differenz von jahr zu jahr
die machen aus eine ganz ganz
unvorstellbar kleine zeit und diese
diese zeitdifferenz von jahr zu jahr
was von er den triumph und sonnen
umdrehungen drehung der erde um die
sonne
von jahr zu jahr die macht eben einen
ganz kleinen wird zeit betrag aus und
diesen zeit betrag konnte man erst durch
die erfindung einer quarzuhr also einer
besonderen technik überhaupt ihres
messen und diese quarz wo ich weiß nicht
wann sie ja von oder so erster hälfte
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts vielleicht
1920 oder 30 erst als man diese quarzuhr
konstruieren konnte er konnte man diese
minimalen zeitdifferenz überhaupt messen
als systemisches problem auch ein
bisschen ja wenn wir das natürlich nicht
messen können dann scheint das alles so
ganz konstanz seien aber genauer
hinschauen dann mit der atomuhr und
weiteren verfall
änderungen der messung können wir
natürlich sagen dass also die drehung
der erde um die sonne
dass die nicht jedes jahr genau gleich
lang braucht dann ist auch die rede vom
jahr höchst problematischen und es
wissen sie wie man mittlerweile eine
sekunde überhaupt physikalischen
definiert wie man dabei verfährt das
können sie auch mal nachlesen
genau das sind als elektromagnetische
wellen also es geht um so ganz kleinste
konstanten erstaunlicherweise sehr ins
kleine und nicht mehr sehr groß
und da wenn sie das mal nachlesen es
hochinteressant wie man diese kunde
definiert physical schnell es ist
natürlich eine bewegung und einstrahlung
elektromagnetische strahlung die frage
ist immer was ist denn jetzt genau
strahlung ist es eine welle ist das
teilchen ganz schwierig aber man hat
jetzt offensichtlich dass eine lösung
gefunden aber es ist hochproblematisch
ich denke auch in diese richtung könnte
man jetzt auch wenn jetzt newton
sicherlich glaubte dass die erde sich
jedes jahr genau gleich lang um die
sonne drehe
jedenfalls ist es eben nur eine konkrete
bewegung an der die zeit bemessen wird
und nicht die zeit als zurück ist es
eben ein ding die erde
die eine bewegung durch fühlt und
dadurch zeitlich betrachtet werden kann
aber nicht die zeit als solche und also
das hatten wir auch bei aristoteles
gesehen hat das tut das wusste das
einfach nicht dachte noch einen ganz
anderen in kosmologischen dimensionen
was jetzt drehungen anbelangt und sofort
habe je genauer man hinschaut umso
unsicherer wird einfach die zeit
bestimmt mittels bewegung solcher
partner
der absolute raum verbleibt vermögens
seiner natur und wohne beziehung auf
einen gegenstand stets gleich und
unbeweglich
es muss natürlich raum heißen der
relative raum ist ein maß oder ein
beweglicher teile des ersten liga von
unseren sinnen durch seine lage gegen
andere körper gezeigt ungewöhnlich für
den unbeweglichen raum genommen würde
zum beispiel ein teil des raumes
innerhalb der erdoberfläche ein teil der
atmosphäre ein teil des himmels bestimmt
durch seine lage gegen die er hatte der
absolute und relative raum sind dasselbe
an art und größe aber sie bleiben es
nicht immer an zahl bewegt sich zum
beispiel die erde so ist der raum
unserer atmosphäre welche in bezug auf
unsere erde immer derselbe bleibt bei
der eine mal der andere teil des
absoluten raumes in welchen die
atmosphäre geht und ändert sich so
beständig also newton versucht jetzt die
absolute zeit in analogie zum absoluten
raum zu bestimmen was ist jetzt hier der
absolute raum den kamera vielleicht ein
bisschen leichter vorstellen als die
absolut bezahlt haben sie eine idee was
ist der absolute raum im vergleich zu
plus relativ frauen
ihr habt sie haben jetzt schon gesund
bezugssystem ins spiel gebracht dann
müssen wir schauen wie sich dann
leibnitz dazu verhalten wird mein
leibnitz wird ja sagen es ist also die
relation die den raum die zeit ausmacht
also ich denke man kann mit blick auf
den relativen raum natürlich wie der
name schon sagt besser von relation
sprechen
der absolute raum hätte natürlich wie
sie glaube ich sagen keine nationalität
wäre eben unabhängig von konkreten
positionen
vielleicht gehen wir mal weiter noch der
ort ist ein teil des raumes wie schnell
körper einnimmt und nach verhältnis des
raumes entweder absolut oder relativ er
ist ein teil des raumes nicht aber der
platz oder die lage des körpers oder die
ihn umgeben der oberfläche denn die orte
gleicher fester körper sind stets
einander gleich wogegen die oberflächen
wegen der ähnlichkeit die gestalt
meistenteils ungleich sind die lage
eines körpers hat aber eigentlich gar
keine größeren ist nicht so sehr ein ort
als ein verhältnis des ortes bewegung
des ganzen ist identisch mit der summe
der bewegung seine einzelteile daher die
ortsveränderung des ganzen identisch mit
der summe der ortsveränderung seine
einzelnen tag
er befindet sich daher innerhalb des
ganzen körpers
jetzt geht es also um spezielle
positionen innerhalb des raumes und
jetzt kommt der entscheidende punkt über
die absolute zeit sagt jetzt absolute
zeit wird in der astronomie von der
relativen und der gewöhnlichen der
falschen der nicht mathematischen durch
die zeitgleich unterschieden die
natürlichen tage welche gewöhnlich als
zeit maße für gleich gehalten werden
sind nämlich eigentlich ungleich das ist
dass alle hat schon gemerkt dass die 1
tage also praktisch die im zeitlichen
abschnitt die jetzt die die prägung die
erde betrifft das die nicht identisch
sind und aristoteles schien davon noch
ausgegangen dass sein dass also
kosmologische bewegungen kosmologische
konstante wie der name schon sagt
konstant sein kostenlos heißt schmuck
ordnung also das weltall ist nach der
vorstellung der antiken einfach absolut
geordnet nach ganz klaren verhältnissen
wie ja auch in der musik frequenzen und
toni der sich nach ganz klar
mathematischen velten stimmen lassen so
ging man mit antik auch davon aus dass
sich tage und jahre im absolut was ihr
dauernd lange denken sondern gefahren
und das ist selbst für newton nicht mehr
der fall
also sagte die sage sind nämlich
eigentlich ungleich diese ungleichheit
verbessern die astronomen dem es die
bewegung der himmelskörper nach der
richtigen zeit messen ist möglich dass
keine gleichförmige bewegung existiere
durch welche die zeit genau gemessen
werden kann alle bewegungen können
beschleunigt oder verzögert werden
allein der verlauf der absoluten zeit
kann nicht geändert werden
das ist also zum beispiel das jetzt auch
mit dieser auslenkung der erde also mal
fünf meter weiter hinter die sonne ist
der radius mal 55 meter weiter oder fünf
meter größer und im nächsten jahr ist
findet mir der kleine du sind einfach
solche relativen verhältnisse die uns
keine absolute zeitbestimmung unmöglich
alle sich hier eben um beschleunigungs
verhältnisse geht nicht um konstante es
geht eben um gravitation hat da wo die
sonne im spiel ist wo sich die erde um
die sonne dreht damals mit
gravitationskräfte zu tun
auch wenn sich die erde jetzt in ihrer
umlaufbahn eingependelt hat natürlich
dieses gleichgewicht aber es ist nicht
ganz konstant allein der verlauf der
absoluten zeit kann nicht geändert
werden
dieselbe dauer und dasselbe verfahren
findet für die existenz aller dinge
statt
mögen die bewegung geschwind oder
langsam oder 0 sein
ferner wird diese dauer von ihren durch
die sinne wahrnehmbaren massen
unterschieden und mittels der
astronomische gleichung aus ihnen
entnommen die notwendigkeit dieser
gleichung bei der bestimmung der
erscheinung wird aber sowohl durch die
anwendung einer pendeluhr als auch durch
die verfinsterung des der jupiter
trabanten erwiesen haben sie hier
nochmal informationen über die absolute
zeit als ich ihr wissen jetzt jedenfalls
was die kritik an der relativen zeit ist
die könnte man auch als eine kritik an
der ästhetischen zeiterfassung verstehen
wenn ich es recht sehe das total es hat
eben zeit und bewegung also praktisch
dass das maß der bewegung ist die zeit
oder die zahl der bewegung ist die zeit
also dreimal die umkreisung erde um die
sonne sind eben drei jahren als er gegen
musste wohl von konstanten verhältnissen
in der kosmologie ausgehen und newton
sagte nennen
das können wir gar nicht
tage sind nicht genau gleich und ob er
das mit dem jahre schon vermutet hatte
weiß ich nicht natürlich leichter einen
tag zu messen die abweichung von tagen
als von von jahren dass ein längerer
zeitraum aber im prinzip her ist es
dasselbe wie mit dem jahr nehmen wir
dürfen nicht sagt newton die
zeitbestimmung nach bewegung innerhalb
eines stimmten systems sondern wir
müssen wenn wir von der absoluten zeit
eben von etwas reden was eben ständig
mit sich identisch bleibt
schau doch mal hierdurch noch mal diese
stellung dieser zeit habe genau er sagt
hier allein der verlauf der absoluten
zeit kann nicht geändert werden
dieselbe dauer und dasselbe fahrend wird
für die existenz aller dinge statt
wie kann man sich das noch vorstellen
haben sie da noch ein bisschen weitere
erklärung dafür
also es muss offensichtlich dasjenige
seien von dem aristoteles sprach als er
gesagt hat damit wir überhaupt
bewegungen veränderungen feststellen
können was sind schneller ist was
langsam ist müssen wir so eine konstante
sind konstanten hintergrund haben
das ist nicht verändern nur an diesen
konstanten hintergrund veränderung
gemessen werden kann
jetzt hatte er ist ottl ist gesagt diese
konstanz die beziehen wir aus der
veränderung aber der gleichmäßigen
fender und die gleichmäßig veränderung
ist eben die erdbewegung und da sagt
jetzt eben newton nein offensichtlich
nicht wir müssen öffentlich die
erddrehung oder sonst die kosmologische
verhältnisse ansetzen um die absolute
zeit diesen absoluten hintergrund zu
bestimmen sondern wissen sagen es ist
die absolute zeit absolute zeit die
absolut gleichförmig bewegung jetzt kann
man sich natürlich fragen ist diese
absolute zeit etwas was wirklich
existiert oder ins minus und postulat
und nur so eine idee dass eine hypothese
annehmen müssen
das ist natürlich eine spannende frage
haben sie sonst noch gedanken zur
absoluten zeigt wie man sich vorstellen
kann
nun ist
[Musik]
sie liegen die gehören die zwei auszug
aus dem aufsuchen zeiten
bis jetzt ist die einheit den gelsen
guter gute beschreibung ich habs jetzt
eine zusammenfassung so habe ich es
gelernt ein gefäß ist ein großes gefäß
problematisch war im gefäß natürlich
wieder mehr verheimlichen ist
wir tendieren dazu die zeit immer auch
zu verheimlichen
das hat zum beispiel dann im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert martin heidegger sehr
treffend in seinem werk sein und zeit
auch gesagt wir müssen aufpassen dass
wir die zeit eben nicht gegenständlichen
dass wir es nicht als eine substanz
hasen und als kein subjekt vielleicht
subjekts wäre vielleicht sogar noch fast
das beste und wir sollten sie auch nicht
freundlicher und so eine rede von etwas
absolut und legt schon so ein bisschen
nahe dass hier ist um so eine
gegenständlichkeit geht also die rede
von einem gefäß von einem vielleicht
konstant verfließen dem gefäß wenn man
sich das überhaupt vorstellen kann wäre
vielleicht sowas wie ein mögliches bild
für die absolute zeit muss das enthalten
und es muss aber getaktet sein netzwerk
finde ich auch nicht schlecht
untergebracht und können richtig genau
was die zeiten muss einerseits sich
bewegen oder es muss muss veränderungen
ermöglichen sagt jetzt mal muss die
bedingung sein dass überhaupt sie etwas
ermöglichen verändern kann und in diesem
ermöglichen von veränderungen darf es
eben selbst nicht verändert sein weil
sonst könnte ja garnicht bewegung
veränderung gemessen werden aber er dann
sagt er wiederum sie verfliest tiefer
fließt
in zeiten da kommen wir jetzt gleich
weiter genausogut gute punkt also
theologisch implikation noch mit
einkommen und da kommen wir jetzt noch
gleich darauf zu sprechen war jetzt geht
es dann in der zweiten hälfte dieser
heutigen sitzung um diesen briefwechsel
zwischen juden und den zwischenräumen
clark also samuel clark ist ein schüler
von newton und leibnitz schauen wir ob
wir hintenan zitat haben wie die
reihenfolge der zeit teile ist auch die
der raum teile unveränderlich wegmann
diese von ihrem orte so werden sie
sozusagen von sich selbst entfernt die
zeiten und die räume sind die orte ihrer
selbst und aller dinge in der zeit in
bezug auf die aufeinanderfolge im raume
in bezug auf die lage aller die das
wesen der räume ist dass sie ortes sind
dass ein ursprünglicher ort bewegt werde
ist absurd genauso natürlich dass eine
ursprüngliche zeit verließ ist absolut
diese sind daher die absoluten orte und
aus der übertragung von einem ort zum
anderen entsteht die absolute bewegung
könnte daraus noch was für sich
mitnehmen
das sind die bestimmung des absoluten
raum ist in der absoluten zeit anbelangt
mit der zeit das ist nicht der
absicherung ist im westen verschieben
außen namen aufschreiben
ja man könnte sich das vielleicht wird
so ein koordinatensystem vorstellen also
ein fixes koordinatensystem irgendwie
also das wird jetzt eben bei newton
nicht relativ gedacht bloße verhältnis
ist und schon absolut es gibt also
dieses fixe koordinatensystem dass wir
vielleicht zum idee aber das wird nicht
irgendwo auf
und das ist eben unendlich so ein
koordinatensystem wählen vielleicht so
eine mögliche erklärung und wenn wir das
jetzt also in bezug auf den raum wenn
wir das zogen jetzt auf die zeit denken
könnte man sich vielleicht überlegen so
eine
somit wäre die einfach sich unendlich
erstreckt wäre das eine mögliche
beschreibung der absoluten zeit sondern
so eine beere einfach diese drei
unendlich nach links und nach rechts
würden sie sagen also das wäre
vielleicht seine versuche das zu
beschreiben
nein
abbilder versehen
interesse besteht versuchen zu finden
und das war tatsächlich in betrieb so
dass geben ja und physikalische
eigenschaften
das war alles ein wenig trinkt machen
wenn dann haben wir das vielleicht mit
einem 3 sterne so ein bisschen regen von
system und beinhaltet fällt raum und
zeit und das donnern
vielleicht meinten sie diesen minkowski
raum also so eine art trichter so ein
trichter genau sowas
ja immer und kalt ist aber eher nicht
auf
nur dass hier so ein kegel
genau das ist der mit kowski raum hat es
ist eben ein raum der praktischen raum
zeitliche vorstellungen
also hier haben wir die zeit und die
haben wir den raum und demmin kowski
raum ist definiert in seiner äußeren
grenzen durch die lichtgeschwindigkeit
also dass der raum jetzt nicht so groß
ist also dass er dort das ich noch nicht
so kommt hängt damit zusammen dass die
lichtgeschwindigkeit begrenzt ist und
diese begrenzung der
lichtgeschwindigkeit äußert sich in
diesem sogenannten minkowski raum mit
kowski war eben der name ist der name
eines forschers darin dass gerade hier
jetzt diese grenzen liegen weiterer
breiter kann nicht sein und breiter sein
zu müssen müsst ihr nicht geschwindelt
die absolute geschwindigkeit absolut
schnellste geschwindigkeit einfach
größer
das ist also der raum in dem sich
überhaupt etwas befinden kann zu einer
jeweiligen zeit genau weil die zeit aber
eben sich auch weiter ausbreitet dann
also wenn wir jetzt eben derzeit
weitergeben hierher
dann ist eben dann hier geht er wie so
ein trichter lieber weiter aber das
hängt eben mit der zeit zusammen das als
praktisch nur eine eine praktisch eine
raum zeitliche vorstellung des urknalls
in dem sinne dass die
lichtgeschwindigkeit die grenzen der
dass der raumzeit einfach definiert
außerhalb dieses trifft das kann nicht
existieren weil nicht schneller als
licht sein kann bekommt er noch darauf
zu sprechen er in der übernächsten
sitzung oder vielleicht zur nächsten
wenn wir uns mit albert einstein fassen
und der der lichtgeschwindigkeit und
ihrem verhältnis zur zeit ja
[Musik]
zum glück
die
guter punkt genau jetzt ist es eben
interessanterweise diese konstante
dieses absolute was man immer sucht ist
jetzt eben nach einstein nicht der raum
und nicht die zeit es gibt nicht die
absolute zeit sondern es gibt eben nur
die absolute richtgeschwindigkeit die
absolute bewegung gibt sozusagen als
eher steif und bei aristoteles ist ja so
dass die bewegung ja immer
unterschiedlich sein kann wir uns dann
nach solchen sternen also nach solchen
kosmologischen verhältnissen richten
müssen es ganz interessant wie sich
plötzlich die absolutheit physikalische
größen ende spannend und eigentlich also
sogar so intuitiv würde man doch schon
denken dass also eine bewegung
eigentlich immer schneller verlaufen
kann warum sollte eine bewegung oder die
geschwindigkeit irgendwo mal eine grenze
an
das läuft doch überhaupt nicht ein wie
sollte die maximale geschwindigkeit bei
ungefähr 300 tausend kilometer pro
sekunde liegen wie sie nicht bei 305
oder bei 330.000 wieso gerade da das ist
doch überhaupt nicht als philosophisch
jetzt oder so von selbst vom allgemeinen
gesunden menschenverstand überhaupt
nicht ein weil ich ja wir müssen
natürlich dann auch versuchen zu klären
wie diese forderung der absoluten
lichtgeschwindigkeit mit versuch vision
prinzipien zusammenhängen wie fenster
empirisches ins spiel kommt also da
nicht doch das theologische problematik
teilten ist in dieser forderung der
absolute lichtgeschwindigkeit das
wirklich absolut gelten muss oder ob man
das nicht auch in frage stellen kann
es sollten dass ich mich als eine
philosophie das dogma annimmt die physik
geht zwar davon aus aber wir sind ja
keine physiker wir sind ja philosophen
und philosophin und dürfen dann noch ein
bisschen weiter fragen ohne uns
anzumaßen die sache besser physikalisch
zu verstehen als physikerinnen und
physiker tun aber wir dürfen jedenfalls
wie wir es als besuchen
und naiv zurückfragen umfragen könnte es
nicht auch eine schnellere
geschwindigkeit geben
warum denn nicht das ist unsere aufgabe
zu fragen
dann müssen die physiker oder wer auch
immer uns eine kluge antwort darauf
geben also dass nur als kleiner vorgriff
auf das was noch kommt jedenfalls
kümmert festhalten hier bei dieser
klassischen physik sind es raum und zeit
die absolut sind und die bewegung eben
nicht die kann eben nur innerhalb des
absoluten rahmen sind absolut zeit
entstehen und die moderne physik sagt
nein nein die bewegung oder die
geschwindigkeit ist das was absolut ist
im sinne dieser grenze das ist diese
grenze
klasse sind die konstanten und eben
nicht raum und zeit also vielleicht
müsste man sich diese absolute zeit zu
verstehen wie so eine bahn ja endlose
der 1
nach beiden richtungen geöffnet und
vielleicht dann wenn man auch ein
bisschen spekulativer sein möchte eine
die die sich geben ihm unendlich und
wieder schließt an das man sich das dann
so mission kreis vorstellen
auch wenn jetzt natürlich die zeit die
enden der zeit sich natürlich nicht mehr
wieder schließen aber sie kennen ja
solche spekulationen ob sich parallelen
unendlichen schneiden
jetzt hört die fragen ob das so ist und
man nimmt es ja an bardelli geraten dass
die sich unendlich einschneiden und
insofern könnte man es spekulativ
vielleicht sagen gut dann lassen wir
einfach jetzt wenn wir den zeitstrahl
der bereich um endlich beide richtungen
verlaufen lassen wir sie einfach dann im
unendlichen sich schließen und fassen
das dann einfach so auf vielleicht jetzt
eher so ein bisschen zur
veranschaulichung und wir können das
dann natürlich wieder in verhalten und
handeln hier diese
absolute zeit streckung der bären also
über das ist jetzt das was mir am
plausibelsten erscheint diese absolute
zeit als seine bären aber jetzt nicht
nur als irgendwelche relationen in der 3
das wäre zu schwach und so wird ja auch
dann leibnitz argumentieren dass es nur
relationen sind sonst schon eine reihe
also betonung auf reihe
es ist eben diese reihe die da eben
unendlich existiert und in der irgendwas
vorkommen kann bewegung stattfinden kann
und so aber es muss schon diese reihe
existieren was auch immer jetzt diese
rein ist als gegenstand vorliegt wie
auch immer als gefäß gedacht werden muss
aber so ein gefäß da haben wir die freue
mich umdrehen und bei einer reihe haben
wir nicht die form nicht drin warum
nicht mal eine neue reihe ist eben gut
meine reihe kann auch sagen vorher
nachher das ist auch so ein bisschen das
problem insofern von der reihe zu
sprechen
impliziert schon so ein bisschen die
verheimlichung funktionieren also wenn
ich sage also es geht nach links und
nach rechts ins unendliche
sowas hier geht es zurück hier geht es
nach vorne
ja da mache ich auch eine vermischung
derzeit aber nur zweidimensional nicht
drei dimensionen wenn ich sage die zeit
ist ein gefäß dann verheimliche ich die
zeit in dritter dimension ist hatte ich
noch viel schlimmer als in der zweiten
dimension zu verheimlichen
deswegen so mein vorschlag lassen wir
sie doch einfach dann sich hier wieder
schließen hier nun endlich und haben wir
hier so eine schön kreis natürlich auch
wieder was was räumliches aber also ich
würde es stark tendieren zur b 33 und
logisch gedacht sie existiert bereits
existiert jetzt nicht nur in ordnung
oder sortieren geistig so entsteht ein
nicht apps theologisch so einfach diese
schere bei dieser schiere fluss etsch
elastisch betrag
journalistisches zeitverständnis also
wir erheben uns über diese zeit drei und
sich in der zeitreihe tränen das was für
uns gegen wird die vergangenen zukünftig
ist ich glaube dass wir so ein kandidat
für diese absolute zeit wäre ein
interessantes thema von der hausarbeit
der begriff der absoluten zeit bei
newton wie müsse man sie denken ohne sie
zu verheimlichen
ohne sie zu verzeichnen im schlechten
sind ein spannendes thema jetzt kommen
wir zu diesem sehr netten herren hier
dem gottfried wilhelm leibniz und seinem
briefwechsel mit samen clark system
leibnitz war ein zeitgenosse new times
hat mit dem auch korrespondiert und
beide haben wir für sich reklamiert die
entdecker der infiniti siebenmal
rechnung zu sein also solchen
verhältnissen ableitungen das deck zu
haben
ich weiß gerade gar nicht wer sie jetzt
wirklich entdeckt hat ob es wirklich
beide zugleich waren also jedenfalls
waren beide mathematiker philosophen und
naturforscher leibnitz vielleicht noch
ein bisschen mehr philosoph als newton
war
wir sehen das auch darin dass er jetzt
in diesem briefwechsel mit samuel clark
und semmel clark war ein schüler von
newton als praktisch eine art von
stellvertreter auseinandersetzung also
praktisch die bleiben jetzt mit clark
debattiert debattierte eigentlich mit
newton also klar ist ein anhänger von
jugend und wir sehen das leibnitz
vielleicht noch ein bisschen
philosophischer ist wenn man das
überhaupt so sagen kann weil er noch
stärker logische und apps theologische
fragestellungen mit
spiel bringt diese minuten eigentlich
keine rolle spielen als elvis
technologie die erkenntnistheorie ist
nicht so zentral
ok dann schauen wir uns mal die
leitfragen an wie bestimmt leibnitz die
zeit im gegensatz zum newton natürlich
spannend das ist die zentrale frage kann
eine weitere folge ist die wie sich
zeitbegriff mit der a und der b 3
derzeit in verbindung bringen lässt
das ist eine frage die wir uns ständig
hier stellen können wie hängen die
jeweiligen theorie mit a und bereit
zusammen also wo kommt die die gegenwart
das zeit bewusst sein spiel spielt das
eine rolle
wir werden jetzt sehen dass also bei
newton können wir jetzt praktisch sagen
spielt die aber so gut wie keine rolle
die absolute zeit ist gerade das was
absieht von solchen relativen sachen wir
werden dann sehen und das ist eine
hochinteressante entwicklung dass die
bewertung von a und b im lauf der zeit
sich radikal gewandelt hat während jetzt
newton bares toten dessen augustinus
denke ich wird aber nicht so stark da
zwischen verschieden unterschieden
für die gehört das zusammen aber bei
newton ist es jedenfalls die beere und
bei heiliger den wir jetzt ganz am ende
dieses semesters kann gewährt bei dem
geht es so weiter sagt die ara dieses
subjektive zeit sagen die ist
eigentliche zeit und er geht sogar noch
ein bisschen höher hinaus er will diese
aber noch mehr idealisieren oder noch
mehr subjektiven oder vielleicht genauer
gesagt existenzialisten wenn man das
überhaupt so sagen kann also für ihn ist
die arbeit noch gar nicht genug
philosophisch gedacht für ihn muss das
ganze was ja eigentlich schon recht
subjektiv ist jetzt vergangenheit
gegenwart zukunft empfinde für den
verteidiger muss diese arbeit noch
weiter radikalisiert werden
und 10
und alles andere die a und die b 3
sowieso das sind bloße abstraktionen
dieses eigentlich existenziellen zeit
von zugs in der wir uns befinden
sie sehen es gibt ne totale umkehrung
der verhältnisse heiliger und auch die
ganze phänomenologie sagt existenzielle
individuelle individuelle vielleicht
nicht aber existenzielle zeit vollzug
zeitbezug der ist das entscheidende am
zeit betrifft also gerade die
subjektivität ihrer stärksten ausformung
und nicht die messbarkeit und die
absolute zeit das sind alles lose
abstraktionen
da lässt man ganz viele dinge fort und
überhaupt so eine reihe zu kommen da
müssen wir abgesehen vom subjekt derzeit
erfahrung usw
und das ist nicht die unmittelbare zeit
wie wir sie existenziell vorfinden es
gibt immer wieder schwankungen in der
bewertung von a nach b
das sollte man glaube ich auch immer
reflektieren ja und dann natürlich die
frage wir wollen ja nicht nur einfach
sagen was sagt jetzt der was sagt dies
und wir wollen uns auch immer fragen ja
was ist überzeugender also die frage die
wir vielleicht heute auch noch am ende
stellen können ist die sich der beiden
zeiterfassung die von juden oder von
leibnitz überzeugender ist und wenn ja
oder werden wenn wir dafür argumentieren
dass es eine ist dann die frage warum
wie sieht denn jetzt überzeugen dann
bitte
so sagen da keine rolle spielen das
bezieht sich nicht nur auf das
das sind da die jetzt kommen die
ausklammert aber wenn
vermisst oder wissenschaftlich tätig ist
und einer wirklich auf den punkt bringen
bzw
relative infizieren
also ich denke nicht dass es einen
gegner daran weil er wirklich als
mathematiker oder wasser ist
letztendlich bestimmt
sicherlich er würde nicht bestreiten
dass es solche phänomene gibt die drei
zuzurechnen sind habe er nennt sie eben
die falsche zeit also er hat er diese
zwei unterscheidung er hat einerseits
die absolute waren mathematische zeit
und dann hatte die andere zeit und die
scheinen wir müssen jetzt mal ins
original schau im englischen original
aber eine deutsche besetzung sagte die
scheinbare die gewöhnliche ich glaube
sogar auch die falsche zeit also ganz
starke wird und wir können trotz
zurückspringen gehe gerne mal kurz
zurück dass man hier ebenfalls er sagt
die relative scheinbar und gewöhnliche
zeit also falsch sagte jetzt hier nicht
als ist doch eine sehr sehr wie ich
glaube ein bisschen so ein bisschen ab
abwertete also gewöhnlich scheinbare
falsch sagt er nicht aber scheinbar
also ist die also er würde es nicht
leugnen aber der fokus und das worum es
eigentlich geht ist die absolute zeit
weil sie sich matti mathematisch
beschreiben lässt
und das ist halt doch mal was anderes
davon dass wir sagen nein wir müssen uns
mit dieser zeit befassen die sich gerade
nicht mathematisch beschreiben diese
zeit die an unsere subjektivität haft
nicht nur in unter uns unsere subjektive
ist unsere existenz als der heilige
spricht dann wirklich ja nicht mal mehr
von vergangenheit gegenwart zukunft sind
er spricht von extras und nimmt also
vergangenheit wird sich mit einem
anderen begriff sagt gar nicht mehr
vergangenheit vergangenheit ist für ihn
schon zu sehr b33 mäßig so sehr abstrakt
es geht einfach nur um tendenzen und
also bei newton wie mir scheint ist doch
die arbeit dass die bereit dass dieses
absolute zeigt das worauf es ankommt und
die phänomene könnte man sicherlich mit
der scheinbaren zeit der gewöhnlichen
zeiten verbindung bringen aber darum
geht es ihm nicht so sehr möchte diese
absolute zeit betrachten und bei
heiliger und anderen und bergs und so
sehen wir dann plötzlich eine aufwertung
der arbeit und nicht nur einfach so weil
es schick ist sind sie haben ihre
argumente und diese argument ist
interessant also warum sie jetzt
plötzlich sagen wir müssen also mehr in
die richtung der arbeit gehen warum
warum sollten wir nicht wieder so eine
absolute zeit ansetzen und das müssen
wir versuchen einfach im
auseinandersetzung abzuwägen und wie mir
scheint haben wir jetzt hier bei
leibnitz in kleinen wechsel wieder
hinrichtung aber ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher bis zum tragen sinne zu
beobachten ist aber ich glaube nicht
dass er noch so stark wie es noten tat
jetzt auf so was wieder absoluten zeit
behaupten so dass das sondern dass da
sich das ganze wieder etwas bewegung
bringen lässt durchgehen
und jetzt müssen wir einfach mal schauen
was es sagt also was mich angeht zeigt
jetzt leibnitz habe ich mehr als einmal
betont dass ich den raum für etwas bloß
relatives halte wie die zeit für eine
ordnung des gleichzeitig bestehenden wie
die zeit eine ordnung von
aufeinanderfolgende mist denn der raum
bezeichnet als ausdruck der möglichkeit
eine ordnung von dingen die zur selben
zeit existieren insofern sie zusammen
existieren ohne auf ihre besondere arten
zu existieren einzugehen wenn man
mehrere dinge zusammen sieht so nimmt
man diese ordnung der dinge
untereinander war also was kann man
jetzt schon mal anhand der ersten
begriffe hier sagen worum geht vorüber
geht es jetzt hier und worauf legt jetzt
hier leibnitz den fokus im gegensatz zu
new jazz wurden müssen jetzt hier
besonders betonen
hmm
das relative es gibt diese absolute zeit
gibt es nach leibnitz nicht gut jetzt
kann sich natürlich sagen ist nicht die
beere so wie wir sie jetzt die
beschrieben haben nicht auch nur eine
ordnung von aufeinanderfolgenden ja wenn
jetzt meinten dass beim newton die
absolute zeit so was wie diese drei ist
die ist ja in ordnung von
aufeinanderfolgen dann hätte ja leibnitz
auch zum bären vorstellung trotzdem
unterscheiden die sich also muss ist
wohl die frage wie die bären existiert
existiert sie absolut unabhängig von uns
als zeitlich gewesen
oder existiert sie nur in verbindung mit
und salz zeitlich gewesen und ich glaube
leibnitz sagt das zweite also erbringt
diese subjektivität wieder ein bisschen
stärker mit den spielen also eine
ordnung die zeit ist nach leibnitz eine
relative ordnung von
aufeinanderfolgenden eine ortung von
aufeinanderfolge
es geht und dass aufeinanderfolgende und
es geht nicht so sehr um das gefäß oder
den rahmen oder was auch immer im leben
das aufeinander folgend ist das ist
vielleicht der unterschied als von
newton ist das aufeinanderfolgen
das entscheidende sondern das gefäß und
der rahmen in dem er etwas aufeinander
freuen können dass die absoluter seite
und leitet seit meiner langen wir achten
auf das aufeinanderfolgen
vielleicht auch eine gewisse ordnung
aber es ist schon eher dass
aufeinanderfolgende das was in diesen
gefäßen ist wie sehr das gefühl ist zum
schein werden angenommen jemand fragt
und jetzt kommt so eine theologische
dimension ins spiel das ist auch ganz
spannend also das market zunächst mal
irritieren aber leibnitz kunden newtons
sehen behandeln die zeit und raum eben
immer auch von gewissen theologische
kontext kosmologische kontext könnte man
auch so angenommen jemand fragte deshalb
gut nicht alles um ein jahr früher
geschaffen hat wenn dieselbe person den
schluss ziehen wollte dass gott etwas
getan hat wofür man unmöglich einen
grund angeben kann weshalb ebenso nicht
anders gemacht hat so würde man ihm
antworten dass eine schlussfolgerung
wichtig geben wenn die zeit was wäre das
außerhalb der zeitlichen dingen ist weil
es dann unmöglich wäre ein grund zu
finden weshalb die dinge bei
gleichbleibender aufeinanderfolge diesem
und nicht anderen augenblicken
zugeordnet sein und sollten aber eben
dies beweisen dass die augenblicke außer
den dingen nicht sind und dass sie
ausschließlich in deren
aufeinanderfolgende orten und stand
haben welche dieselbe bleibt so dass
sich der eine der beiden zustände mit
derjenige der angenommenen zeitlichen
vorverschiebung in nichts unterscheiden
würde und nicht von dem anderen
unterschieden
werden könnte der jetzt ist
das ist jetzt das argument dass ein
bisschen schwierig wenn ich mir hier
zwei minuten vorstellen kann ich habe da
so bei der heiteren abschluss und
konstrukt dann könnte man es
theoretische auf der zeitachse
verschieden ja die zeit ist die absolute
vertrauen
verschiedene bands gibt es aber diese
achse gar nicht sind das was ich jetzt
verschieben wollte ist eigentlich immer
genug system
es gibt diesen absoluten raum nicht an
dem diese verschiebung gemessen wird
völlig richtig ich glaube sie haben es
richtig formuliert es käme am ende auf
selbe raus auch wenn es zwei jahre davor
werden weil diese absolut raum
diese absolute zeit nicht existiert an
der diese bewegung verschiebung gemessen
werden genau richtig genauso die zeit
bewegen als solche ist irgendwie schon
selbstgenügsam oder soda absolut sie
muss nicht noch einen etwas anderen
derzeit gibt nicht zwei arten von zeit
könnte man auch sagen es gibt nicht
relative zeit bewegung des werdens diese
zwei jahre früher
und dann noch diese absolute zeit die
dagegen dann absolut ist aber dann ans
als solche genommen wie sie ja auch
sagen immer noch im fluss sein müsste
ich glaube das geht in die richtige
richtung haben sie gut er kann
bitte da wäre sie jetzt kennt da wäre
sehr skeptisch sehr skeptischen also
leiten jetzt bestreitet auch dass es so
einen absoluten raum gibt wie es eine
absolute zeit gibt geht immer stark von
denen von den ordnungen innerhalb des
raumes und der zeit aus
wäre letztendlich ununterscheidbar von
anderen möglichen leeren räumen also bei
leibnitz würde dann das was ja es wäre
dann im grunde genommen wenn nicht in
diesem sinne räumlich und es wäre vor
allem auch nicht unterscheidbar nicht
mehr unterscheidbar also für leibnitz
geht es immer darum dass wir etwas genau
identisch es auch wenn es jetzt leer ist
das ist dann kollidiert mit dem anderen
aber sie haben auch recht also das würde
nach leibnitz muss immer etwas im raum
und in der zeit sein um letztendlich
räumlich genannt werden zu können
als erster lehnt eine vorstellung von
einem von raum und zeit als gefäßen
sonst relationen von räumlichen
zueinander
das macht die die verhältnisse machen
erzeugen das räumlich um das zeitliche
und nicht das maß der maßstab oder der
der rahmen innerhalb dessen etwas ist
als er hat eine völlig andere
vorstellung von raum zeit als es eine
auffassung ist die beide als gefäße
denkt er stinkt stärker von den
individuellen dingen her betrachtet aber
wir müssen das vielleicht noch ein
bisschen offen lassen wir kommt noch
darauf zu sprechen im folgenden also er
lehnt wie gesagt das kann man schon mal
sagen sowas zum absoluten raum ohne
absolute zeit ab das haben wir jetzt
schon mal hier jedenfalls gesehen und so
wie sie ist jetzt auch re formuliert
haben
die zeit wird nicht verschoben anhand
eines absoluten maßstabes und lassen
sondern wir können es letztendlich dann
gar nicht mehr relation ihren an einen
absolut maßstab denn es kommt auf das
selbe raus genau
das ist dieser letzte satz habe eben
dies beweist beweist dieser satz ihr
aber eben dies beweist dass die
augenblicke außer den dingen nicht sind
und dass sie ausschließlich in deren
aufeinanderfolgenden ordnung stand haben
welche dieselbe bleibt da sich der eine
der beiden zustände wie derjenige der
angenommenen zeitlichen vorverschiebung
in nichts unterscheiden würde und nicht
von dem anderen unterschieden werden
könnte also letztendlich ist es sowas
für also der punkt ist er wenn wir eine
wenn wir eine zeitliche einordnung von
bewegungen uns denken die exakt
identisch ist von ihrer ordnung und die
uns denken dass sie fünf minuten früher
begonnen hätte genau derselben ordnung
dann wäre es sie nach leibnitz
ununterscheidbar hatte die frühere
ordnung der zeitlichen ordnung die
identisch ist macht nicht das aus beiden
zwei verschiedene entitäten werden zum
sieg konzipieren als die früher der
frühere beginn ist nicht letztendlich
entscheidend für die individuelle oder
sogar für eine ökologische bestimmung
dieser dieser ordnung also es käme auf
dasselbe heraus dass liegt da hängt
damit zusammen dass für leibnitz das
ununterscheidbar
also wenn zwei dinge völlig dieselben
eigenschaften haben dass sie dann kopien
zitieren sie genau dieselben
und offensichtlich dass schließlich
jetzt daraus ist verletzt das früher
beginnen oder später beginnen einer
zeitlich identischen ordnung nichts was
die ordnung selbst als eigenschaft
bestimmt als ob etwas derselben
zeitlichen ordnung früher oder später
mit dieser selben zeitlichen ordnung
begonnen hat endet an der sache nichts
das genau dieselbe sache und deswegen
konzipieren sie und deswegen spielt die
absolute zeit also dieser rahmen anhand
dessen dann diese zeitliche bewegung vor
oder zurück geschoben wird keine rolle
ich denke in diese richtung geht es ja
als ich versuch's mal ein bisschen
grafischen zu veranstaltungen wie nichts
verstehen
also wir nehmen jetzt mal alles geben
ist so einen absoluten absolute zeitung
und jetzt habe ich hier das ist jetzt
mal so eine bewegung so eine ordnung
wieder aufeinander ich kann auch so was
machen so was das jetzt mal eine so eine
ordnung und ob ich dir jetzt ein
bisschen weiter nach links verschieben
genau gleich lang
diese richtung oder in diese richtung
spielt nach leibnitz keine rolle ist
dieselbe zeit eine rolle spielt dass nur
noch newton bei dem wir noch diese diese
absolute maßstab noch in zukunft nachdem
an dem man dann das messen kann
für ihn sind das genau die selben
zeitlich in ordnung
während das interessiert für ihn nur die
zeit und die bleibt die ordnung
innerhalb dieser beträge dieser grenzen
dieser phase nur das interessiert ihn
nicht und nicht die frage noch ob jetzt
das ganze nach vorne und in einer
absoluten zeit nach vorne oder zurück
verschoben wurde das spielt keine rolle
deswegen gibt es für ihn interessiere
nicht praktisch diese diese absolute
zeit diesem sinne so interpretiere ich
das jetzt also für ihn ist das
letztendlich identisch wenn es genau
gleich lang ist sozusagen das haben
wieder eine vermischung der zeit
vorgenommen wenn die genau identisch
sind diese phasen hier dann ist es
völlig unerheblich da machen wir nicht
zwei daraus wenn sie genau gleich groß
werden und zu verschiedenen zeitpunkten
innerhalb dieser absoluten zeit
existieren würden
traktiert wir lesen einfach mal weiter
war noch eine meldung hatte sich noch
jemand gemeldet
[Musik]
ja ich denke es kommt aufs selbe hinaus
wird auch selbe hinaus also wenn es
keine absolute zeit gibt dann sind die
eben auch identisch nur weil dann
interessiert ja nicht mehr das vorher
oder später jetzt im absoluten sinne
sondern nur noch der betrag sozusagen
als ich denke es hängt damit zusammen
dass es nach meistens kein absolut zeit
gibt deswegen sind identisch weil es
nicht relevant ist ob sie früher oder
später gemessen an den absoluten zeit
sind habe es ist eine spannende frage
ich glaube er streitet einfach ab dass
es so eine absolute zeit gibt natürlich
würde auch seinem prinzip der identität
das eben zuwider laufen wir hätten dann
genau dieselben dieselben phasen diese
eben orden das was ich hier
so gezeichnet wie werden genau identisch
wenn man annehmen es gebe zwei
identische ordnungen nur die würden
zeitlich absoluten der absoluten zeit
unterschiedlichen zeitpunkt beginne dann
wäre eben die frage
sie wären ja nur noch unterscheidbar
durch ihre zeit stelle ihre zeit stelle
oder ihre raum stelle im absoluten raum
bzw der absoluten zeit und so wie ich
jetzt dieses zitat lese scheint das für
leibnitz nicht hinreichend dass sein um
eine entität ein ding zu individuen also
erachtet offensichtlich nur auf diese
inneren grenze hier
wenn die dieselben sind dann sind sie
identisch
der spannende frage des müssen jetzt
erst noch mal offen lassen das sehen sie
in anhaltspunkt dass ich daraus folgen
würde würde das nachher schaffen
das ist eine spannende frage auf jeden
fall
er kommt noch darauf zu sprechen wir
müssen das erstmal offen lassen also ich
würde jetzt aus diesen passagen scheint
mir das jetzt wenn ich unmittelbar zu
folgen aber wir belassen es mal offen
erstmals es eine spannende frage
ebensolche grenzfragen was war bei der
schöpfung gab es ein zustand davor wie
verhält sich das mit der existenz gottes
dessen spannende fragen die damit auch
noch ein bisschen zusammenhängen wie wir
ja auch schon bei augustinus gesehen
hatten dass wir ihnen auch diese frage
nach der schöpfung eine ganz ganz große
rolle spielen
es geht aber erstmal weiter ich lese
noch mal vor
also
also wenn der raum um die zeit etwas
absolutes wären
dh wenn sie etwas anderes wären als
gewisse ordnung von gingen
es wäre das was ich gesagt habe ein
video spur
quasi das aber keineswegs sind so ist
die hypothese widersprüchlich das heißt
es ist eine unmögliche erfindung also da
wird einfach nur noch mal gesagt dass
raum und zeit nichts absolutes sind und
daraus folgt verleitet dass sie eben nur
gewisse ordnung von dingen sind was auch
immer jetzt die dinge sind es jetzt
dinge sind da sind es also gegenstände
substanzen
es müssen jetzt mal offen lassen aber
von etwas existiert ordnung von
existierenden
und die räumliche ordnung von
existierenden ist einfach an solche
ordnung die sich beschreiben lässt wie
die iaa ist eben fünf meter weiter links
fünf meter entfernt von ding b
natürlich kann man sich jetzt fragen ist
dann die rede von links und rechts nicht
nur relativ aber jedenfalls fünf meter
entfernt von ding b das ist eine
räumliche ordnung und eine zeitliche
ordnung wäre daneben
das kam vor also hakan vor zeitlich vor
b und hier ist denn die frage natürlich
um so eine ordnung zeitliche art denken
zu können müssen wir tendenziell sowas
wie ne voraussetzt alle müssen schon um
eine ordnung von zeitlichen ding decken
zu können im modus der drei denken
die frage ist jetzt eben nur existiert
die bereits als solche unabhängig von
den konkreten zeitlichen abfolgen das
ist die spannende frage oder sollten wir
nicht nur einzelne episoden im sinne
dieser a und b verstehen dass dieser
bereich verstehen
solche ordnungen die folgen natürlich
der logik der b 3 das hier ist vor dem
hier wenn wir sagen das ist wohl das b
dann ist natürlich hvb aber wir beziehen
das ganze dann nicht noch mal auf eine
generelle zeitliche ordnung also mir
scheint dass newton ebenso eine sehr
starke bereit fast schon substantially
sierung der bre
während leibnitz sony relativierung der
b 3 folgen also bin ich in diesem sinne
dass es eine art wird aber denkt die
bären schwächer als im judentum
denn das kann man zwar wenn wir etwas
haben was nach der bhs strukturiert ist
eine zeitliche abfolge dann müssen wir
die nicht noch mal an einer fixen
[Musik]
bereits messe zu sagen es geht
letztendlich um die relativität von
episoden und nicht um die absolute
verordnung in einem alles fix gedachten
koordinatensystem also dieses große
koordinatensystem in dem sich alles
bewegt das existiert nach leibnitz so
nicht
es existieren die relativen ordnungen
von ereignissen
eben innerhalb der zeitlichen abfolgen
schon da gibt es schon relation also
jetzt wie hier
und wie jetzt wenn das jetzt eins ist
die frage ist halt gut die frage ist an
aufgrund dessen kann man das bewerten
brauchen wir um sowas unterscheiden zu
wollen so eine reihe
die gibt's die gibt's die gibt's schon
für ihn verleugnet es gibt schon
erfolgen
dann hier das war die frage mit diesem
raum dann würde er wahrscheinlich sagen
gibt es keine
es liegt so ein bisschen nachladen
auszuschließen also von der veränderung
auf zeit zu schließen
das ist die zeit und dann kann man sich
vor allem wenn es keine gibt ja aber
keine teilchen die in einer relation
zueinander sind dann würde minuten sagen
gibt es trotzdem die absolute zeit
das wäre wahrscheinlich zu die
konsequenz sagt selbst wenn sie jetzt da
nichts tut es gibt trotzdem die absolute
zeit die als starre rahmen möglicher
beschreibung im hintergrund existiert
und leibnitz wäre da ein bisschen
idealistischen anführungsstrichen er
würde das ganz stark von der bewegung
abhängig machen und nicht sagen auch
wenn sich da nichts tut dennoch gibt es
hinten dieses starre koordinatensystem
die absolute zeit dann ist das gefäß
halt leer sozusagen das raum zeit
gefäßes leer winter gerade nichts und
nicht sich tot
aber es existiert trotzdem und in
leibnitz würde sagen nein dann gibt es
eben kann zeigen kann
die zuvor dessen begleiter zu der
angestellten gleichmäßig über teil
[Musik]
besteht ja sei es geht glaube ich ein
bisschen diese richtung er würde
natürlich nichts sagen dass die zeit
schneller oder langsamer fließen kann
natürlich muss man dann bleiben jetzt
rückfragen ja warum denn nicht wenn wir
keine absolute zeit haben dann kannst du
dann hast du probleme anzugeben dass die
zeit gleichmäßig verläuft ist die
schuldfrage also genau also die gute
frage folgt daraus nicht verleiten ist
dass er nicht zeigen kann dass die zeit
konstant verläuft weil das konnte ja
mutant damit leisten das sagen alle
ereignisse die sie jetzt hier finden wir
sind auch wenn sie sehe diese kurven
haben wir sind immer noch relativ auf
die absolute zeit weil sie geld weil sie
relativ auf die absolute zeit sind
verlaufen sie genau klein schnell auch
wenn der unterschiedliches passen jetzt
laufen genau die zeit verläuft in den
ereignissen genau gleich schnell und die
frage kann diese gleiche taktung
derzeit kann die jetzt leibnitz noch
erklären wenn er so was wie eine
absolute zeit als und starren
hintergrund nicht mehr an das ist das
ist ein problem verleiht das müssen wir
mal so anerkennen
das sagt doch mal was ich habe hier so
ein paar zitate aus diesen zahlreichen
texten rausgefischt sagt dass der raum
lediglich eine ordnung der dinge ist wie
die zeit und keineswegs eine absolute
wesenheit als er wirft jetzt juden vor
den raum und die zeit dazu essentially
sieren also etwas was unabhängig von
bewegung und von zeit ist und das ist
natürlich klar natürlich wenn man sowas
wie ihre augen und zeit als wesenheiten
an dem dann ist es schon schwierig weil
die existierenden traun und der zeit und
die zeit wie existieren die denn an sich
genommen
wir können doch nur räumliches und
zeitliches 10 oder war
wie soll denn existieren ist nicht nur
so eine denkfigur hass und notwendige
denkt bedingt um den gleichmäßigen
ablauf der zeit denken zu können
und jetzt habt ihr aber klar dagegen das
habe ich mal die andere stimme noch
einfach dass das zweite zitat er sagt
dass raum und zeit nicht die bloße
ordnung von mengen sind sind wirklich
hängen maß an ordnung und plage nicht
sind
also das ist ein direkter bezug jetzt
auf das vorherige zitat und das erste
ist jetzt von leibnitz
das zweite ist ja klar inwiefern sind
raum und zeit wirklich
das ist eben dieses wie wir uns das
vorgestellt haben diesen
koordinatensystem dass es eben diese
raume zeitpunkt gibt platzhalter
vielleicht sogar so als platzhalter die
in diesem absoluten raum belegt werden
können wir nicht ja es gibt sie müssen
so verstellen also ständig erkrath
versorgen absolutes koordinatensystem
raum zeitliches koordinatensystem was
also raumzeit punkte gibt nicht nur
räumliche punkte sind auch zeitliche
punkte und die können eben besetzt sein
oder nicht besetzt seien
und es gibt die zeit natürlich auch in
diesem absolut sinn wenn der punkt nicht
besetzt ist jetzt nichts drin ist also
man kann sich das dann durchaus wieder
visionen kowski raum natürlich
vorstellen wie man die
lichtgeschwindigkeit mit nein tut und
sonst müsste man sich also ein kegel
vorstellung und gleichmäßig
ausstrahlendes im koordinatensystem also
das ist jetzt ein punkt der mir jetzt
kommt also als platzhalter raumzeit
platzhalter die besetzt sein können
nicht besetzt sein kann und die als
platzhalter existieren nach juden jetzt
gedacht auch wenn da nichts ist es wäre
vielleicht zu der uni forscher noch von
einer absoluten raum
dann nochmal klar was offensichtlich ist
auch dass die zeit nicht nur die ordnung
der nacheinander folge von denen ist
denn die menge derzeit kein größerer
gerne sein und trotzdem bleibt jene
ordnung die selbe die ordnung des
aufeinanderfolgende verdienten derzeit
ist nicht die zeit selbst denn sie
können und es kommen das argument denn
sie können in derselben aufeinanderfolge
schneller oder langsamer
aufeinanderfolgen aber nicht in
derselben zeit wenn es keine geschöpfe
gebe so wäre doch aufgrund der gegenwart
gottes und der dauer seines reichs
teramo die zeit genau dasselbe wie jetzt
entscheidet ist hier
dieser satz denn sie können derselben
aufeinanderfolge schneller oder
langsamer aufeinanderfolgen aber nicht
in derselben zeit
das war jetzt diesen punkt den wir
vorhin hatten wo man jetzt sagt er aber
leibnitz wenn du jetzt hier nicht diesen
absoluten raum oder beziehungsweise die
absolut zeit an nimmst dann kannst du
doch gar nicht zeigen ob jetzt da was
schneller oder langsamer verläuft auch
die zeit jetzt nicht schnell oder
langsam machen läuft
es scheint mir so ein bisschen daraus
auch zu folgen also wie kann er jetzt
hier die gleichmäßige abfolge derzeit
begründen wenn er nicht so was wie den
absoluten raum wurde eine absolute zeit
annimmt und er würde jetzt eben sagen
klar dass labels sagt die zeit ist nur
die ordnung der nacheinander folge von
dingen
ich habe ist diese ordnung jetzt so dass
die nacheinander folge gleichmäßig
getaktet ist
wohl bekomm ich diese gleichmäßige
taktung sondern bloße nacheinander folge
von denen kann sich schnell und langsam
vollziehen muss ich dann nicht um das
jetzt bewerten zu können auch mal so
einen zusätzlichen rahmen annehmen sagt
aber leibnitz wieder die teile der zeit
wo des ortes sind für sich selbst
genommen dinge die nur in der
vorstellung vorhanden sind deshalb
gleichen sie einander vollkommen wie
zwei abstrakte einer das ist jetzt
wieder ähnliches argument wie das wo man
gesagt hat wir verschieben jetzt die
selben zeit episoden innerhalb der
absoluten zeit und sehen da sie sich
selbst von einander nicht unterscheiden
und das ist hier genau dasselbe also
verleitet wenn ich ihnen recht lese
müssten alle teile der zeit und des
ortes nach seinem absoluten verständnis
von derzeit eigentlich prinzipiell ist
noch unterscheidbar
wie kann es den verschiedenen raumer
zeiten gegeben in duale oder orte alle
identisch sind müsstest du nur noch
einen geben wenn wir das und wenn das
munter schaltbar zusammenfällt und das
ist bei leibnitz ein prinzip das was
unterscheidbar ist muss identisch sein
und sagte also sind nur in der
vorstellung waren also der heimat
sondern in der schlacht system ische
oder geschiedene schwach subjektives
tische auffassung
zeit was wieder ein bisschen mehr
indianer geht weil das subjekt wird ein
bisschen stärker ins spiel kommen
vorstellung vorstellung ist nicht
unlogisch ist was elvis technisches noch
ein zitat da der raum an sich wie die
zeit nur eine in der vorstellung
vorhandene sache ist so kann der raum
außer der welt nur eingebildet seien
dies sogar die show lastiger sehr wohl
erkannt haben
der fall liegt ebenso mit dem leeren
raum in der welt der nicht aus den
angegebenen gründen ebenfalls für
eingebildet hat also den leeren raum den
gibt's nicht sagt bleibt gegen jung und
juden gesagt es könnte so wären kaum
geben wir auch eine lehre zeit die reine
form ist als es an sagt bleibt nein das
ist ein bildet das ist nur im geist in
der vorstellung vorhanden dabei möchte
ich es für heute mal belassen sie sehen
es geht hier richtig schön in ein
konflikt verhältnis hinein zwischen
clark alias oder für newton sprechend
und in leibnitz und ich denke mal können
sagen bei leibnitz gibt es einen
leichten übergangs eine leichte tendenz
zur bab a 3 wenn er jetzt nicht so sehr
die gegenwart und so betont aber das
subjekt was bei newton völlig außen vor
gelassen wurde
das kommt jetzt hier für leibnitz wieder
stärker ins spiel wir haben jetzt noch
ein paar weitere folien bis folie 25.5
folien gibt es noch die finden sie alle
auf die lowcost laden sich die runter
lesen sie noch einmal wir lehrer in der
nächsten sitzung noch mal auf newton und
leibnitz heimgehen und dann in der
zweiten hälfte
der nächsten sitzung auf albert einstein
eingehen auf seine spezielle
relativitätstheorie sitzung